You love to frost with all your heart.
Sometimes when we love someone like that,
we do the wrong things.
He's a doctor.
If you're not Caitlin or Frost,
who are you?
No more going rogue
all that for this
I'm sure it was worth it because I'm kind
of, you know, running out of boomerangs.
Uh, hello?
Creepy.
That's what I'm talking about.
Fine.
What's our next move?
Not quite
the flash Netflix movie
the one signed with him.
Will.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
I got a lot of requests
to do new flash video
because it is the final season,
so I'll explain what's going on.
Obviously, Red Death is like
the big villain that they're hyping up.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here.
I know there's lots of questions
with all the different storylines.
Well, explain what's going on.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Because it's a Super Bowl this weekend,
there's going to be a bunch of trailers.
The Flash movie trailer is also going
to be dropping new footage.
I'll do a video for that as well, too.
It'll be a good weekend.
There'll be a lot of flash related stuff
happening this year
just because the Flash movie,
they're going to reboot
the big DC universe.
I'll explain that too,
because James Gunn did say
that they're using the flash point twist,
which they already did on the Flash
TV show to reboot all of these movies.
We've been theorizing they were going
to do that for a long time now.
Sure is a nice timeline. Be a shame
if someone messed that up.
Where have I seen that before?
Oh yeah, that's right on the Flash tbh.
That was like one of the themes
of the first three seasons of the show.
Going to be real weird
if Grant Gustin doesn't
have some kind of cameo
or John Wesley Shipp
just hoping for a couple of small cameos
in The Flash movie
when they're crossing
through the multiverse.
Just start with the big stuff here.
Obviously, Red Death, huge character
fusion of Batman and the Flash,
but from a much darker timeline, The Flash
showrunner explained a little bit
about how they're adapting the Red Death
storyline because in the comics
is basically a fusion of Batman
from the Dark Multiverse,
who's taking The Flash's powers
and combine them with his own, using
the cosmic treadmill
that he's fuzed with his Batmobile.
Like it was a really crazy
origin story, really cool storyline
a couple of years ago,
but it was a much bigger part of the Dark
Knights metal storyline, and there were
a couple of major storylines
that the Flash showrunner teased
that they had planned on developing.
Had the show gone to Season ten?
I'll explain those later too,
because some of the Easter eggs
from earlier seasons led up into that.
Originally, the red Death was meant to be
one of the nightmare versions of Batman.
Like you have a bunch of different
versions, basically from the Dark
Multiverse, taking the powers of the Major
Justice League Heroes in Red Death,
which is like the version of the Flash,
the twisted version of the Flash.
But on that earth, Batman had turned evil.
That was the whole twist.
It was a bunch of evil versions of Batman
taking the powers of the heroes.
Would that he's with This version of Red
Death is that it seems like it's from
either an alternate dark future timeline
or an alternate earth
in in the earlier trailers
the flash is talking about
how they're trying
to construct a time travel device.
And it sounds like that's tied
to the storyline from episode one, where
Barry's really excited for his future
notebook is basically
like a book of spoilers,
where he has everything that's
going to happen in the future written down
so that they can follow like a plan
and avoid all the bad stuff.
Obviously, the minute
that someone whips that out in an episode,
you know
they're going to change the timeline.
They the crazy Groundhog's
Day twist in the episode.
But Iris also said
that she didn't want the future notebook,
which is basically the show telling you
that they're not going to be
following the notebook,
which is why he burns it
at the end of the episode,
setting out the whole idea
that the timeline will eventually change
in all the things that Barry thought
were going to happen
aren't going to happen
in the same way or happen at all.
And it sounds like it has something to do
with the big red death twist.
Like Red Death is trying to construct a
time travel device and change the timeline
so that something different winds up
happening in the future.
And as part of this scene, you see red
Death giving all this advanced hyper tech
advanced weapons to the new version
of Captain Boomerang during the episode.
They wonder how he got such advanced
technology.
It's probably just future tech
and it probably means red
Death is from an alternate future.
The Flash showrunner said that
they're not doing the exact same
Dark Knights metal storyline.
Obviously that got really crazy.
There were a whole bunch of Justice League
characters.
This version of Red Death is meant to be
a fusion of Batwoman with an alternate
future version of The Flash, or somehow
has gotten Speed Force powers and it just
sounds like she's from a dark future
timeline and she's trying to change that.
And as part of that,
she's commandeered a bunch of flash rogues
and is using them to construct
a bunch of technology
that she'll use to construct
a time travel device.
I don't know if the Red Death storyline
is supposed to last all season
because the way the Flash
has been organized
the past couple of seasons is they divide
major villains up in chunks of episodes.
So like they'll do a bunch of episodes
with one villain,
then move on to the next one.
But for instance, characters
like The Reverse-Flash, they'll bring back
multiple times during the season,
so they might do the same thing
with the Red Death character.
Like that might be something
they finally resolve in the finale.
They are bringing back Matt Fletcher
as a version of Eobard Thawne.
They are bringing back Eddie Thawne.
So there are a bunch of other big twists
that they'll introduce in future episodes.
In the trailer
footage, Flash's Talking to Kill Blaine
after the events of Episode one,
where he found the new version of Caitlin
Snow Killer Frost.
They use the cryogenic chamber
at the end of Season eight to try
and bring her back using vestiges of her
left inside Caitlin In an earlier season,
they use a twist to separate
her personality.
So they were like two separate bodies.
One was regular Caitlin
Snow with a regular personality,
the other was just meant to be Frost
They start calling her killer.
Frost
and they just started calling her Frost.
Then earlier in season eight,
she sacrificed herself to kill Des Storm
by absorbing him.
And speaking of Des storms,
since he was like
the Black Lantern version
of Ronnie Raymond Firestorm
during Black Night in the comics,
the Flash showrunner just revealed
that he had originally planned on doing
Blackness night during Flash Season ten.
Had the show gone for another season?
I think early on,
when they were developing the show,
everybody had theories about the big
storylines that they would eventually do.
Blackest Night was always on the table,
like, Oh, maybe at some point
they'll do a version of Blackness night
across the Arrowverse too,
because it was such a big comic book
event.
It sounds like the Arrowverse version
of Blackest Night
would have been related
to Dingle's Green Lantern ring,
and they would have incorporated
more Green Lantern stuff into the series.
And they did have a version of Hal Jordan
on the show in Arrow Season four
episode one.
So there is a Hal Jordan
in the arrowverse.
It was kind of the same way
they had a Bruce
Wayne Batman in the arrowverse,
but there are all kinds of crazy rules
about how they were allowed
to use the character because at the time
they had all these crazy movie plans
for the bigger characters.
Obviously the big James Gunn DC reboot,
all those plans have changed now.
I just did a huge video for that,
so I'll link it
at the end of this
and down to the description below.
They are doing a big Green Lantern
HBO series,
but they said it's going to be more like
True Detective inside the DC
Universe with how Jordan and Jon Stewart
set on Earth.
Okay, the next thing is a big premiere HBO
television series called Lanterns.
This is a story of a couple of green
lanterns, Jon Stewart
and Hal Jordan, and we have a few other
lanterns peppered in there.
But this is really a terrestrial
based TV show, which is almost like true
detective with a couple of green lanterns
who are space cops
watching over precinct Earth.
In it, they discover a terrifying mystery
that ties into our larger
story of the DCU,
and they'll be uncovering a mystery
that'll have something to do
with their next big Justice
League team up movie.
It sounds like that was one of the reasons
why they changed all their Diggle
Green Lantern plans.
When you see
the new character in the trailer
picking up the violin case and fighting
what seems like the Pied Piper
in the rain, if you couldn't tell
she's holding a violent like a fiddle,
marking her as the new fiddler character.
So it sounds like episode two
is going to be a big Fiedler versus Pied
Piper episode because you see Pied Piper
asking for Kayla like, I need a doctor.
Somebody help me.
The fiddler is a long time flash road.
The last time we saw
the character was during season
four as the Izzy Bone
version of the character.
I'm assuming they're using
the Big Multiverse reboot during Crisis
on Infinite Earths to say that this person
became the fiddler in the new timeline
the same way they use the Big Multiverse
reboot to reimagine a lot of flash roles
with new versions or younger versions,
or the children of the previous rogues.
Some of them are old actors coming back.
Like some of them,
they haven't changed that much.
Some are children of the previous rogues
who just taken up the mantle,
and some of them are just flat out
bringing new versions.
But in most cases, they're trying to base
most of them on comic book versions.
And that's just par for the course
for the flash rogues in the comics
over the last like 50, 60 years.
Reason I tracked you down and continue
to be the best you could possibly be.
Axel, I
am your father.
They've explained a little bit
about what's going on
with the killer Frost Caitlin Hybrid.
Now she's supposed to be a good character
and help the team during the season,
especially in the finale.
Like she's supposed to have something
really big
that she'll do to help them
in the last episode.
That might have something to do
with the Red Death storyline.
It just depends on
how long they keep that character around
because The Flash died in each timeline
and restarted the timeline.
When he died, it made it seem more like
the episode was inspired by the zero anime
look The Flash got the main characters
return from death ability.
It's a great anime series
if you haven't seen it before,
but I'm assuming it was more inspired
by Groundhog's Day
just because they tend to go
with bigger pop culture references.
The other small Easter egg
in the background here too.
There's another Batman Easter egg.
If you didn't spot the Krakatoa Club
where you see
the new fiddler fighting Pied
Piper is actually a Batman villain,
or the name is taken from a Batman villain
who looks kind of like Molten Man.
They kind of had a version of Molten Man
in episode one,
but it was like a hallucination
that Barry was having.
Speaking of Batman and TV series,
they actually did just release
a teaser for the new Batman
HBO series based on the Penguin character.
Matt Reeves is doing a bunch of Batman
HBO series spinoffs of the Robert
Patents and Batman series.
They actually already started
filming the series, so I'm assuming
it'll take them all year to finish it,
and they'll air episodes next year.
It's supposed to take place
between the events of the Batman movie
in the Batman Part two.
They're just calling the second Batman
movie Batman Part two right now.
I'll probably do a much bigger video
about that later this weekend
because it does seem like it's
going to be really cool.
Colin
Farrell has been hyping it up big time.
If you have any questions or big requests,
just leave them in the comments below.
There's a bunch of big stuff
happening this week.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss it.
Everyone click here for that
brand new flash movie trailer
with a bunch of new footage,
including for that new Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania video to learn
why Kang started the Multiverse war in the
first place.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.